we were talking about the fact that you
had muslims here
in sarajevo in bosnia that they were
actually helping tell us talk to you
about the history they were helping to
save the jews
going to the extent of even putting them
in the cab or the islamic dress is that
yes yes during the world war
ii uh the muslims and the bosniaks
people in sarajevo in the whole of
bosnia and herzegovina
are protecting the jews
like wearing the niqab wearing the
uh especially in the cup
yeah was the the they would put they
would put
under the jewish and uh
muslims would put this on the jews
to hide the yes behind his house
yes yes
so the nazis wouldn't kill them yes yes
yes yes
protect them the jews from the nazis the
muslims were protecting the jews from
the nazis by putting them
in the islamic very very interesting
thing
that the people knows that
[Music]
till 1949
all women in sarajevo muslim women
are wearing the niqab and i think uh
1949 communists have
forbidden the kneecap so here right here
in this area on the
other cities from bosnia
yes and 1949 i think 1949 the communist
uh forbidden wearing uh
subhanallah